so energy price cap is the maximum
you're expecting to pay for your energy
bills for the average household in the
UK for a year now the previous price cap
was uh well over 300 000 pounds but we
had the energy support scheme that
helped bring that down so it may
essentially you would never pay more
than two and a half thousand pounds a
year for your bills now we've just had
the new price kept up just in the past
few moments it's now
2074 pounds so that will bring your
bills down and the reason this matters
is because the energy support scheme is
ending in July when this press cap
begins and therefore that is the kind of
prices people can expect to be paying
for their annual Energy bill now
obviously it's good news because bills
are going down about 400 450 pounds from
what they're paying at the moment per
year the only issue is it's still
massively expensive and it's still
really really high compared to
pre-pandemic levels and we're not
expecting energy bills to go down you
know to prevent pandemic levels until
the end of the decade so energy balls
are still going to stay very very high
and still going to be very very
expensive for a lot of households okay
we're going to speak to the head of Off
Gym actually in about 10 minutes time
see what he's got to say about it all